Au cours des années 1970,
l'armée de l'air décide de se lancer
dans un programme d'intercepteurs lourds.
Cet avion du futur sera trop coûteux
pour les moyens de l'État français.
Mais de son étude naîtront deux projets.
Le Mirage 2000, dont le développement
se fera avec un financement public,
et le Mirage 4000, avion biréacteur,
dont l'étude sera laissée à
la charge de l'avionneur Marcel Dassault.
Le Mirage 4000 effectuera
son premier vol en mars 1979,
quasiment un an,
jour pour jour, après le Mirage 2000
dont on connaît la suite de la carrière.
Le Mirage 4000 était
un appareil réellement extraordinaire.
Son concept révolutionnaire et moderne
ouvrait déjà la porte à la polyvalence.
Hélas, il était surdimensionné
pour les besoins français, et beaucoup
trop cher pour l'armée de l'air
qui devra se contenter du Mirage 2000.
Mais au moment même
où l'armée de l'air se lance à fond
dans le programme Mirage 2000,
une autre réflexion s'engage
sur un futur avion de combat tactique
qui devra succéder au Jaguar et
ancien Mirage à l'horizon des années 90.
L'armée de l'air exprimait
le besoin d'un avion de combat
offrant une polyvalence
élargie et équilibrée
qui permettrait de remplacer sept
types d'avions à l'horizon 2000-2010.
Le Jaguar, pour les missions
d'attaque air-sol et la reconnaissance.
Le Super Etendard,
pour les missions d'attaque au sol
effectuées à partir de porte-avions.
Le Crusader, pour les missions embarquées
de couverture aérienne du groupe naval.
Le Mirage F1, avion multirôle
de bombardement et de reconnaissance.
Des Mirage 2000 N et D, pour les missions
d'attaque de précision et d'interdiction
au moyen d'armes
nucléaires ou conventionnelles.
Le Mirage 2000 C,
pour les missions de défense aérienne
et de sûreté de l'espace aérien.
Le Mirage 4, pour les missions nucléaires
et les missions de reconnaissance.
Deux de ces types d'avions devraient
être embarqués à bord de porte-avions
avec toutes les implications résultant de
cette capacité de projection de forces :
déploiement rapide,
autosuffisance en matière de support
et contraintes d'espace.
Des discussions concernant
la définition d'un avion ultra polyvalent
s'étaient ouvertes dès 1978 entre la
France, l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne.
En prenant en compte
les besoins énoncés par chaque pays,
cet avion devra savoir tout faire.
Dès 1980, alors que les négociations
au niveau européen se poursuivent,
Dassault propose le lancement
d'un programme de démonstrateur
purement national
qui portera le nom d'ACX.
La course ne fait que commencer mais,
pour Dassault, que le programme commun
aboutisse ou pas, le niveau de compétence
de son bureau d'études doit être préservé.
En septembre 1982,
à l'occasion du salon de Farnborough,
les Britanniques présentent
une maquette taille réelle
de leur propre démonstrateur technologique
baptisé ACA pour Agile Combat Aircraft.
Le 12 novembre de la même année,
Charles Hernu, ministre de la Défense,
annonce le lancement du programme
d'avions de combat expérimental ACX.
La mésentente se profile à l'horizon
et, en 1985, les chemins vont diverger.
Paris quitte alors
la table des négociations.
La France veut un appareil léger,
capable de se poser sur des porte-avions
et assez polyvalent pour remplacer à
terme tous les avions de l'armée de l'air.
Par ailleurs, la France disposait
d'industriels jaloux de leurs compétences
et qui voulaient rester
maîtres du jeu et de la technologie.
La France décide
de développer le Rafale.
Le 4 juillet 1986, Dassault fait
voler le Rafale A, premier démonstrateur.
Propulsé par deux
réacteurs General Electric F404,
l'avion laisse très
rapidement entrevoir son potentiel
et l'on peut déjà dire
que le génie de Dassault
éclatera une nouvelle fois au grand jour.
Le Rafale sera un avion formidable,
promis à une grande carrière.
Il sera de ces avions mythiques
qui resteront à jamais dans les mémoires.
Dans le camp adverse,
quatre pays européens s'unissent
pour mettre en place
le programme Eurofighter.
Leurs idées s'appuyaient
sur l'exemple américain.
Commander en plus
grand nombre pour réduire le coût.
L'Espagne et l'Italie rejoignaient
donc l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne
dans ce programme.
Le pari de faire baisser les coûts
grâce à la coopération échouera totalement
et cette coopération
se montrera souvent contre-productive.
L'Eurofighter est,
par exemple, le seul avion du monde
dont l'aile droite et l'aile gauche
ne sont pas fabriquées au même endroit.
Les bureaux d'études de Dassault
mirent les bouchées doubles.
Des moyens informatiques
extrêmement modernes et performants
furent mis en œuvre
pour améliorer l'avion.
Celui-ci remplissait
pleinement son contrat
en validant cinq innovations majeures :
formule aérodynamique,
utilisation généralisée de matériaux
nouveaux, commandes de vol électriques,
poste de pilotage révolutionnaire
et intégration générale des systèmes.
Mais le Rafale A
ne reste qu'un démonstrateur
et le bureau d'études
de Dassault doit encore travailler
pour réduire sa taille et sa masse,
qui dépasse d'une tonne le poids
des avions de série qu'il préfigure.
Une cellule d'essais
est installée au CEAT de Toulouse.
24 h sur 24, des vérins
torturent littéralement l'avion,
simulant plus de 200 vols par jour pour
étudier le vieillissement des structures.
Ces essais joueront un rôle essentiel
dans la maîtrise de la masse de l'avion.
Une fois de plus, les ingénieurs de
Dassault ont fait les choses bien et vite.
Et le 19 mai 1991,
le Rafale noir prend l'air
avec près de
trois années d'avance sur l'Eurofighter.
Le Rafale C01 va pouvoir
entamer une série d'essais et, déjà,
il présente des différences
significatives avec le Rafale A.
Par exemple,
il est dépourvu d'aérofrein,
ce qui est une première
dans les avions de combat.
Le pilote dispose néanmoins
d'une fonction aérofrein par une commande
qui entraîne automatiquement le
positionnement des plans canards à piquer,
tout en braquant
les élevons de façon différentielle.
Les ingénieurs ont fait
là l'économie de la masse,
et d'une installation
hydraulique spécifique.
Les essais en vol vont continuer,
et la traque
aux sophistications inutiles est ouverte.
Les solutions
les plus simples sont retenues
car synonymes
de l'allègement de l'avion
et réduction des coûts
d'acquisition et d'entretien.
Les premiers vols
se passent sans histoire
et l'avion est immédiatement utilisé
pour expérimenter le domaine de vol,
tester l'interface pilote-avion et surtout
valider l'emploi des réacteurs M88.
Les capteurs embarqués dans l'avion
transmettent en direct, en salle d'écoute,
les données qu'ils enregistrent.
Les ingénieurs de vol reçoivent
et analysent les flux de données
ainsi transmis.
Le pilote peut, ainsi,
dialoguer avec les ingénieurs
et effectuer des opérations
spécifiques à la demande.
Le M88, développé par Snecma,
est un moteur hautement modulaire
afin de réduire son entretien.
Il bénéficie également
des dernières avancées
pour réduire la signature
magnétique et infrarouge.
Avec une puissance
de 50 kilonewtons plein gaz sec
et 75 kilonewtons avec la réchauffe,
il offre un rapport poids-poussée élevé.
Comparé à l'Atar 9K
qui offre la même puissance,
il est plus court
de moitié et plus léger de 45 %.
La compacité du M88
n'est pas sans intérêt.
Elle permet de réduire la taille du Rafale
de série par rapport au démonstrateur.
La cellule sera plus fine,
les entrées d'air plus étroites,
donnant à l'avion
une silhouette plus compacte
et surtout moins de traînée,
améliorant ainsi les performances en vol.
Au-delà de ses qualités,
le M88 est un moteur très économe.
Le Rafale C01 effectue sans aucun
problème, en configuration lisse,
des vols de près de 2 h 30.
Lors de son entrée en service,
le M88 doit être déposé
et vérifié toutes les 150 heures.
En janvier 2001,
ce chiffre passera à 500 heures,
représentant environ
deux ans d'utilisation opérationnelle.
Avec l'étape quatre,
on passera à plus de 800 heures
et à la fin 2005, tous les M88
bénéficieront d'un rétrofit en version E4.
Fort de ce résultat spectaculaire,
Snecma continue le développement du M88
qui devra donner, dans l'avenir,
toute une famille
de moteurs pour avions de combat.
L'appareil prend part
aux essais d'armement
avec les essais
de séparation des missiles.
Le logiciel Catia, véritable bijou,
permet, dans un premier temps,
de vérifier l'exactitude
des calculs en effectuant des simulations
qui feront gagner,
une nouvelle fois, un temps précieux.
Des essais en vol
complèteront ces études
et permettront d'optimiser
l'emploi des différents armements
lorsque l'avion sera opérationnel.
Face aux besoins de l'aéronavale,
en matière de remplacement
de sa flotte de Super Etendard,
la marine nationale envisage un temps
de faire l'acquisition
de F18 pour quelques temps.
Dassault imposera le Rafale
à l'issue d'un nouveau bras de fer
car le danger
de voir des avions américains
de longues années sur les ponts
d'envol des porte-avions français
pesait trop lourdement
sur l'industrie aéronautique nationale.
Après une période de tension,
qui n'aura que pour effet de retarder
une nouvelle fois son développement,
le prototype M01effectue ses premiers
vols et ceux-ci rassurent immédiatement.
Le Rafale Marine sera un bon avion.
Définitivement, on peut dire
que le bureau d'études de Dassault
fait les choses bien.
En effet, les ingénieurs
ont abordé le problème dans le bon sens,
en partant sur la base d'un
Rafale Marine qui sera allégé plus tard
pour être en adéquation
avec les besoins de l'armée de l'air.
Les essais,
qui ont commencé en décembre 1991,
vont se poursuivre
jusqu'en février 1993.
Le M01 va effectuer
plusieurs campagnes embarquées
et même subir
une série de catapultages
sur une installation
terrestre aux États-Unis.
De retour de cette campagne,
au cours de laquelle il effectuera
plus de 24 vols en configuration lisse,
sans aucun problème, le M01 se
posera pour la première fois sur le Foch,
piloté, pour ce grand
événement, par Yves Kerhervé.
Le catapultage aura lieu
le lendemain et sera suivi par une série
de neuf catapultages et appontages.
Avec deux avions disponibles,
le développement s'accélère
et des essais peuvent avoir lieu
simultanément en France et aux États-Unis.
En 1994, le démonstrateur
effectuera son dernier vol
en compagnie
de quatre autres prototypes.
Le programme se déroule normalement,
et Serge Dassault
ne cache pas sa satisfaction
de montrer que c'était le bon choix.
Nous avons voulu
démontrer que le programme Rafale
se déroule parfaitement,
conformément aux prévisions,
et que nos cinq
prototypes sont en état de vol.
Nous avons aussi fait
voler le premier démonstrateur,
dont aujourd'hui c'est le dernier vol,
puisqu'il a terminé, si je puis dire,
sa carrière de mise au point et d'essai,
nos deux Rafale Marine
et nos deux Rafale Air, dont le biplace.
Ces cinq avions sont parfaitement au point
et le programme se déroule parfaitement,
conformément aux prévisions.
Nous tenons les délais
et nous tenons les performances.
Il aura un énorme succès à l'étranger,
d'autant plus que, dans les années 2000,
nous pensons, tel
que l'on peut prévoir aujourd'hui,
que la concurrence américaine,
qui est très forte aujourd'hui,
le sera beaucoup moins, étant donné
que nous ne voyons aucun concurrent
à l'horizon de programme
et de notre avion Rafale.
Les années qui vont suivre vont voir
se multiplier les démonstrations en vol.
Toutes les occasions
de présenter l'avion seront bonnes,
et Dassault
ne manquera aucune d'entre-elles.
Toutes les versions seront
présentées comme ici, au Salon du Bourget.
Mais ces efforts ne verront pas
se concrétiser
assez vite
les commandes du gouvernement.
De report en report
d'une commande française,
l'avion se heurte à un mur
sur le marché de l'exportation.
Son rival, l'Eurofighter,
effectue les mêmes campagnes,
mais il est servi par un carnet de
commandes en meilleure forme.
On peut se douter
que la vérité est tout autre,
et que lui aussi
est soumis à d'autres contraintes.
Malgré la satisfaction
affichée des présentateurs en vol,
la situation est tendue
et la concurrence s'organise.
Les Soviétiques viennent
en force participer à nos meetings
en présentant leurs Soukhoï Su-27
et autres MiG-29 qui,
il faut bien le reconnaître, ont de
quoi séduire au moins le nombreux public
par leur forme plutôt agressive
et leurs évolutions remarquables.
Le 4 décembre 2000, les premiers
Rafale M se posent à Landivisiau.
Pour la marine,
c'est un véritable renouveau.
Le Rafale dégage une image
remarquable mais doit de nouveau essuyer
les plâtres de décisions
politiques en faveur des économies.
L'étape d'un avion de présérie
va être tout simplement annulée.
L'économie financière est appréciable,
mais aura l'inconvénient
de laisser à la charge
des marins le déverminage de l'avion.
Avec beaucoup de philosophie,
dans un contexte tendu,
les mécaniciens
et les pilotes vont faire leur travail
avec un très haut niveau
de compétence et de motivation.
Il s'ensuivra, sur un pont
et des ateliers parfois encombrés,
une utilisation optimale
des capacités de base du Rafale.
Avec en moyenne huit avions
disponibles sur les neuf embarqués,
le Rafale brille par son excellent
taux de disponibilité en opération.
La mission Héraclès
fut un succès et, aujourd'hui encore,
le Rafale participe activement,
en compagnie des Super Étendard,
à faire face à des offensives
particulièrement vigoureuses
de la part des talibans.
Avant d'être en activité dans
les escadrons, les avions font un passage
au Centre d'expériences
aériennes militaires de Mont-de-Marsan.
Le lieutenant colonel Vialle
nous explique comment intervient le CEAM
dans la vie de l'avion.
Le rôle du Centre d'expériences
militaires dans l'armée de l'air
est de définir des consignes
d'emploi, des procédures de maintenance,
concernant tous les appareils
nouveaux, les nouveaux matériels,
qui entrent
en service dans l'armée de l'air.
Dans un premier temps,
nous avons eu des équipes amont
qui ont suivi tout
le développement du Rafale
depuis de longues années
auprès d'industriels,
en ayant toujours un regard
opérationnel sur cet avion.
Toujours avoir
un oeil critique opérationnel
dans les solutions proposées
par l'industriel au futur client
qu'est l'armée de l'air.
Ensuite, nous avons reçu ici,
il y a environ deux ans,
les premiers exemplaires du Rafale
au titre de l'expérimentation,
la prise de compétences :
voir concrètement comment utiliser
l'avion, dans le domaine
de la maintenance,
dans le domaine
du vol opérationnel.
Dès l'instant que nous avons acquis
une certaine expérience au sein du centre,
nous avons commencé la transformation
des premiers équipages des forces,
en l'occurrence
les équipages de l'escadron de chasse 1/7
nouvellement opérationnel sur cet avion.
Les 20 premiers exemplaires
du Rafale sont passés entre nos mains
au titre de la maintenance,
de la montée en puissance.
Mais dès l'instant
que nous avions terminé la transformation
d'un noyau dur d'une quinzaine de pilotes
et de huit navigateurs sur Rafale,
à partir de cet instant là,
l'escadron a été transféré
sur Saint-Dizier avec ces appareils.
C'est une grande première
au sein des forces françaises.
Nous avons décidé, avec la
marine nationale, d'expérimenter en commun
la version Rafale F2,
la version armée de l'air
et la version marine,
puisque les marins,
à compter de l'été 2007,
auront une flottille
opérationnelle sur cet appareil.
L'inauguration officielle de
l'arrivée du Rafale dans l'armée de l'air
a eu lieu le 27 juin 2006,
sur la base de Saint-Dizier,
en présence du Premier ministre
et du ministre de la Défense.
Le 1/7 Provence dispose aujourd'hui
d'une vingtaine d'avions opérationnels.
L'ensemble du personnel, pilotes et
mécaniciens, sont désormais familiarisés
avec un avion aux capacités
qui ne cessent de les séduire.
Le lieutenant-colonel
Vincent Chusseau était pilote en échange
au sein de la 12ᵉ
flottille sur la version F1 du Rafale.
Il connaît bien l'appareil et confirme
qu'il progresse de façon significative.
L'arrivée de l'avion dans l'escadron,
est l'aboutissement pour tous
d'une longue période de préparation.
Cet avion marque
l'avènement de nouveaux concepts
en matière de préparation
des vols et de maintenance.
Dans son emploi au quotidien, le Rafale
affiche une simplification des tâches,
très appréciée, tant pour le
pilotage que pour l'aide à la navigation.
Le capitaine Gilles Valet,
ancien pilote présentateur de Jaguar,
nous présente
cet avion véritablement unique.
Dans le Rafale,
c'est un mini-manche latéral
qui ne bouge pratiquement pas.
Une grosse manette des gaz
côté gauche, avec un faible débattement.
Ensuite, pour piloter, on a un gros
viseur où on a beaucoup d'informations :
le vecteur vitesse, l'altitude,
le cap et diverses informations
concernant le tir air-air et air-sol.
La vision tête moyenne
où il y a toute la situation tactique.
Une télévision à droite,
une télévision à gauche.
En fonction de la phase
de vol dans laquelle on est,
on peut
afficher différentes infos :
à gauche notamment tout ce qui
est contre-mesures électroniques,
et à droite,
par exemple, la vision avec l'OSF.
Donc à droite, le mini manche latéral
ou stick, avec un petit débattement.
Comme vous voyez,
là c'est le débattement max.
Ensuite, une dizaine
de boutons sur cette manette.
Un des boutons principal,
la petite pyramide ici,
qui consiste à piloter l'avion.
Quand elle est sous pilote automatique,
on donne des petites impulsions :
haut bas droite gauche.
On pilote l'avion comme ça.
Les gros boutons ici sont
essentiellement liés aux différents
modes du radar,
aussi bien en air-air qu'en air-sol.
Pour délivrer l'armement,
il y a une queue de détente
comme sur tous
les avions qui se trouvent derrière.
On tire comme un pistolet.
Voilà pour le manche.
Pour la manette des gaz : une grosse
manette des gaz en deux parties.
Voilà le débattement max.
Plein gaz sec
et après pleine charge PC.
Le petit bouton
pour les deux radios : vert et rouge.
Les aérofreins.
Ici, pour bouger la petite croix
dans la situation tactique
pour désigner des objectifs,
par exemple.
Sur la partie prolongée,
on change les échelles
de la situation tactique.
On trouve divers boutons
pour régler le radar également.
C'est un avion très facile à piloter.
Moi qui ai fait
du Jaguar ancienne génération,
je n'ai pas éprouvé
de difficulté particulière.
Le fait que ce soit un mini manche
latéral, ce n'est pas un souci.
On s'y fait très rapidement,
en quelques secondes
on a pris l'avion en main.
Après, la difficulté,
c'est de bien intégrer le système.
Mais le pilotage pur
de l'avion est très, très simple.
Il n'y a pas de grosses difficultés.
Les qualités
et les défauts de l'avion.
Les qualités,
c'est qu'on a toutes les infos
dont on a besoin : infos radar,
Spectra, la guerre électronique, l'OSF,
l'optronique secteur frontal,
la liaison de données.
Tout cela, c'est le système Rafale,
ça fait beaucoup d'informations.
Un pilote de chasse
son métier n'est pas de piloter.
Le pilotage est un outil
et le but est de réaliser la mission.
Le pilotage,
pour nous, c'est transparent.
C'est un outil comme un autre.
Pour détecter les différentes menaces,
dans un premier temps on a le radar.
Ensuite on a l'OSF,
l'optronique secteur frontal.
C'est une petite boule
qu'on voit sur le nez de l'avion,
et il y a une caméra
avec une voie infrarouge
et une voie télévision.
En fait, on voit vraiment,
en temps réel l'objectif,
un avion ou un objectif au sol,
sur lequel on va désigner
des bombes par exemple.
On a aussi la liaison
de données avec un AWACS
ou un centre de contrôle
au sol ou entre chasseurs.
Entre Rafale,
on peut s'échanger des informations
via la liaison 16
et le transfert de données.
Et on a aussi pour terminer Spectra,
le système de contre-mesures électronique
quand un avion nous éclaire.
En fait, on va savoir
de quel côté vient la menace
et on a aussi
une bonne estimation de la distance.
Voilà les principaux
capteurs de cet avion.
La grosse différence avec le Jaguar,
c'est évidemment la puissance.
Bien que le Jaguar
était un avion fantastique,
il était sous motorisé.
Là, on a quinze tonnes
qui poussent derrière.
Ensuite les capacités
de manœuvrabilité de l'avion.
On a vu que ça reste un delta
auquel on a rajouté des canards,
donc l'avion est bien
plus manœuvrant qu'un Mirage 2000.
Voilà la grosse
différence avec un Jaguar.
C'est très confortable
d'avoir de la puissance.
C'est sûr qu'on n'en a jamais
assez, mais par rapport à un Jaguar,
ça change beaucoup la vie.
On est plus confortables,
on a plus d'aisance dans nos missions.
De même que pour le personnel
navigant, l'étendue des possibilités
que le Rafale et son système de soutien
offre au personnel technique est énorme.
Ce point de vue
nous est très bien expliqué
par le responsable
du soutien du 1/7.
C'est un avion
qui est tout à fait facile à maintenir
puisqu'il a été conçu pour ça
et depuis le début du programme.
Ainsi, pour le Rafale,
on travaille avec son principe
d'une maintenance selon état.
Les avions d'ancienne
génération type Mirage 2000 ou Mirage F-1
étaient arrêtés de façon périodique
pour être complètement revisités
et complètement vérifiés.
Sur le Rafale, nous n'avons plus
ce genre d'opérations de maintenance
et donc nous gagnons
forcément en disponibilité de l'avion
puisque en permanence
les équipements de l'avion
sont vérifiés en temps réel
et nous ne sommes plus obligés
d'arrêter l'avion
pour vérifier les équipements.
L'intérêt du Rafale,
c'est que le concept de maintenance
a été étudié
dès le début du développement,
et cela a été vrai également
pour la formation des mécaniciens.
L'armée de l'air
a profité de l'arrivée du Rafale
pour vraiment effectuer une
révolution dans les systèmes de formation
des jeunes mécaniciens
en regroupant certaines spécialités.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons
trois spécialités au niveau du Rafale :
une spécialité vecteur
qui s'occupe du dépannage de la cellule
et du dépannage des moteurs,
une spécialité armurier
qui s'occupe de tout ce qui est
siège éjectable et de l'armement.
Et une grosse spécialité avionique qui
s'occupe de tout ce qui est électricité,
électronique, capteurs
et informatique à bord de l'avion.
Le moteur modulaire nous permet évidemment
de travailler beaucoup plus vite.
C'est le principe
du moteur modulaire.
On enlève un module,
on le remplace par un autre
et le moteur redevient
disponible tout de suite.
Et ensuite, il y a une autre étape
où le module est réparé.
Le moteur est disponible
donc l'avion peut voler.
Donc ce concept
n'est pas révolutionnaire pour nous.
On a déjà commencé à travailler
comme ça avec le Mirage 2000.
Maintenant, l'intérêt du moteur pour nous,
mécaniciens en unités opérationnelles,
c'est qu'il est beaucoup
plus facile à maintenir et à dépanner.
Un nombre incroyable d'opérations
qui nécessitaient auparavant
une dépose du moteur
se fait aujourd'hui moteur avionné.
Aujourd'hui, on peut changer
un calculateur sur le moteur du Rafale,
avec le moteur avionné.
Le plus gros changement
pour la maintenance du moteur
sur le Rafale,
c'est l'échange du moteur.
L'échange du moteur
se fait très rapidement.
En moins de trois heures
le moteur est changé sur Rafale.
Comme on facilite
le travail des mécaniciens,
la conception de l'avion
fait également qu'on a moins de matériel
à mettre en place autour de l'avion,
moins de moyens de soutien à mettre pour
le dépanner. C'est d'autant plus rapide.
Un avantage également
très très intéressant pour la technique,
qui est évidemment
tout à fait utile pour les opérationnels,
c'est la sécurité centralisée sur l'avion.
Aujourd'hui, la sécurité centralisée
sur l'avion fait qu'en tirant une manette,
l'avion est complètement sécurisé.
Les pilotes préparent
quotidiennement leurs missions.
Les données de vol sont
consignées par le navigateur, par exemple,
dans une cassette très complète.
Tout est pris en compte :
plan de vol, bibliothèque électronique,
situation tactique
ou encore pré-réglage des capteurs.
La mission, c'est une strike.
On a une notion
d'organique très restreinte,
c'est-à-dire qui se résumera
plutôt à de la self-protection,
puisque de toute façon
il n'y a pas d'autre strike.
Le but est de tirer de l'AASM
sur la base de Saint-Dizier.
À l'issue du briefing,
les équipages se préparent
et regagnent les avions
en étant certains d'effectuer leur mission
dans les meilleures conditions.
Traditionnelle signature
de la forme au bureau piste,
et direction le parking.
Le navigateur remet
la cassette au technicien
chargé de la préparation de
son avion, qu'il insère dans le logement
pendant que le pilote
fait un tour d'avion simplifié
du fait de la réduction des paramètres
à vérifier, la majorité des sécurités
étant automatisées
par une commande située en cabine,
comme par exemple,
la sécurisation des emports et des bidons.
Dans le moteur,
pas de carburant.
Le brélage lui aussi est simplifié
par la sécurisation du siège éjectable
par le pilote lui-même et la mise
en route peut avoir lieu très rapidement.
Les moteurs M88 nous font
entendre des sons impressionnants
dès leurs premiers tours de fan.
Les avions rejoignent le taxiway dans le
grondement plutôt mélodieux des réacteurs
et s'envolent
pour une mission lointaine.
L'Escadron effectue journellement
des missions comme la participation
à la permanence opérationnelle
assurant la sûreté du territoire.
Malgré quelques soucis
de jeunesse, l'avion se montre fiable
et sa polyvalence
en fait un avion roi.
De retour de vol, on remarque
que contrairement aux Mirage 2000,
il n'y a pas
d'armurier en bout de piste.
La mise en place des broches de
sécurité est une tâche qui a été supprimée
car c'est le pilote
qui sécurise là encore son avion
depuis sa cabine.
Celui-ci regagne directement
le parking pour être préparé
pour la mission suivante.
Le modernisme du Rafale
nous étonne encore à chaque rencontre.
Plein de carburant,
vérification des organes extérieurs,
l'avion est très
rapidement prêt à repartir.
De jour et de nuit,
les missions s'enchaînent
et une sérieuse montée
en puissance s'opère,
surtout depuis que l'escadron
est doté de 20 appareils.
Le 1/7 a acquis la capacité à
intervenir hors des frontières nationales
dans le cadre
des opérations extérieures.
Mais il est investi d'une autre
mission de la plus haute importance :
la formation des équipages
des deux escadrons
devant recevoir
les Rafale après lui.
La mission peut imposer
de procéder à un ravitaillement en vol.
Cet exercice ne présente,
bien entendu, aucune difficulté
mais il faut remarquer que
la frugalité des réacteurs M88-2 de Snecma
contribue à la réalisation
de missions de longue durée.
Le Rafale dispose d'une capacité
d'emport en carburant de quatre tonnes
700 en interne
et de six tonnes 800 en externe.
La charge externe peut être
mise en place sur cinq points d'emport.
Dans ces configurations,
le Rafale peut effectuer
des missions de ravitaillement
de type Buddy-Buddy
là où l'espace aérien
n'est pas accessible aux avions citernes.
Un Rafale du CEAM effectue,
sous nos yeux, un ravitaillement
en compagnie de Mirage 2000.
Le Rafale peut tout à fait
participer à des opérations nocturnes.
Les équipages s'entraînent là
encore le plus possible.
Mais cet exercice est limité
à une sortie hebdomadaire
pour réduire les nuisances
sonores pour les riverains des bases.
Le système d'arme du Rafale
a été conçu pour permettre l'utilisation
sans restriction
de tous les armements actuels,
connus et à venir, quel que
soit leur degré de sophistication.
Avec une masse
à vide d'environ dix tonnes,
le Rafale est doté
de quatorze points d'emport.
Cinq d'entre eux sont
spécialement adaptés aux charges lourdes
et le poids des emports
externes peut dépasser neuf tonnes.
Le premier, et le plus important,
capteur du Rafale est son radar.
L'agilité de son faisceau,
grâce au balayage électronique,
et sa vitesse de calcul permet en air-air
la détection et la poursuite automatique
de plusieurs cibles
simultanées et à grande vitesse.
Il permet l'élaboration
en temps réel de cartes 3D
pour le suivi de terrain
et l'affichage d'une carte 2D
pour la navigation
avec génération d'images haute définition
et détection de
cibles terrestres ou maritimes.
L'interface homme-machine,
unique au monde, combinant le concept
main sur manche et manettes,
s'appuie sur un ensemble d'équipements
à haut niveau d'intégration
qui permettent aux pilotes
le pilotage tête haute,
l'analyse de la situation tactique,
l'acquisition et la
désignation visuelle rapide de cibles,
la gestion des ressources système.
La fusion des données multi-capteurs
permet d'établir un véritable lien
entre l'espace global
du champ de bataille qui entoure l'avion
et le cerveau du pilote,
avec sa capacité unique
à comprendre les implications
d'une situation tactique
et à prendre la décision la meilleure.
Le dernier né
des avions Dassault ne se contente pas
d'embarquer la gamme la plus large
et la plus avancée de capteurs.
Il en décuple l'efficacité
grâce à une technologie
radicalement nouvelle.
Capable de combiner des missions
d'attaque au sol et de combat aérien
durant la même sortie,
capable d'accomplir simultanément
plusieurs tâches telles
que le tir air-air à longue distance
pendant une phase
de pénétration à basse altitude,
le Rafale est aujourd'hui
un avion hautement opérationnel.
Le Rafale n'est plus
un avion de démonstration en vol
comme le sont ses principaux rivaux.
C'est un avion
à la capacité omnirôle élargie
alliée à un très haut
degré de survivabilité.
En service dans l'armée de l'air,
le Rafale devrait connaître
un succès mérité
sur le marché de l'exportation,
et ses concurrents russes
et américains, malgré leurs prouesses,
peuvent véritablement
redouter le roi du ciel.